understand that this is a fluid
situation so there's not a lot of
information that we can release at this
time
agents are still at the scene of the
incident
conducting interviews and gathering any
evidence that's relevant to the
investigation so it's a very fluid
situation
you're going to hear from tbi director
david rausch she's going to give you the
latest
on the investigation also knoxville
police department
chief eve thomas is on hand to provide a
status update on the officer
who was injured thank you
thank you leslie thank you officer
at the request of the sixth district
attorney general sharm allen
tbi special agents are investigating the
circumstances leading
to an officer-involved shooting that
occurred this afternoon in knoxville
preliminary information indicates that
approximately 3
15 pm the knoxville police department
received a report of an individual that
was
possibly armed with a gun at austin east
high school
upon arrival officers located the
individual in the school
in a restroom they ordered him out but
he refused to comply
as officers entered the space the
subject
reportedly fired shots striking an
officer
one officer returned fire he was
pronounced
the suspect was pronounced dead at the
scene
and has since been identified as a
student at austin east
the officer who was shot was transported
to a local hospital for treatment
at this time the investigation remains
active
and ongoing as tbi agents continue
to gather any and all relevant evidence
interviews and information throughout
the process
investigative findings will be shared
with the district attorney general's
office
for her further review and consideration
and that's all i have for now and i'll
turn it over to chief thomas
our officer was shot at least once in
the upper leg
he is in serious condition and is
currently in surgery
and that's all i have um we offer our
prayers
our thanks to tvi um for stepping in to
do this investigation
but um our prayers for the family and
for the suspect who passed um but that's
all i have at this time
can you tell us that the officer was the
srl
i can't tell you that at this time
not yet can you talk to us a little bit
about what it's like for
you to get this call this afternoon go
to the school that's
that's we've been to so many times in
the last few months
what went through your head it was just
very chilling
first of all to hear we have an officer
down and secondly that it was out of
school
it's just it's a sad day for the
knoxville in our community
and our police department
i have not intended to hit that way
afterwards so i can hopefully see him
when he gets out of surgery
perhaps uh mr roush can you can you give
us a little
insight into how this investigation what
happens next
sure um so what's currently going on is
we still have agents on the scene
uh they're going to gather all obvious
the evidence there
uh we'll be reviewing uh microphone
we'll be reviewing uh the video evidence
from the officer's body on cameras we'll
be
reviewing video evidence from the school
itself
knox county security is working closely
with us
to assure that we have all of that and
so those are all pieces
of of the effort so and then there'll be
interviews
uh that'll take place of all potential
uh witnesses
uh as well as obviously anyone that was
involved
uh that that's pretty much the the the
typical uh process
you said that this happened when there
was a suspect in the restroom of the
school
um the suspect the student now you've
confirmed that as well
officers responded that can you describe
anything about that encounter how long
it lasted how long it took
we're still way too soon in the
investigation to get into those type of
details
do you know if other students were
around again way too soon
uh we we're still gathering all of that
information
uh we've yet to review video and so that
will give us even more
uh the detail of what we need to know
there were three people involved the
suspect that left
us like two sros is that correct
no but we we're not sure what the status
of the officers are other than their kpd
officers
uh so i i don't know what their role
yeah
right law enforcement officer one
alleged suspect
there may have been more officers on the
scene uh again we
we're working through all that we know
that there were additional officers that
were responding and so
at the time of the shooting we're not
exactly sure yet how many were actually
present so
uh we do know that one officer returned
fire and then so
any indication that the student was in
the restroom preparing to do anything
with the gun that he had brought to
school or was there
so they could stop something or was that
just him in the restroom they caught him
there yeah
yeah all that's still too preliminary to
to have that detail and no arrests were
made
no arrests that i'm i'm familiar with at
this time
that someone may have been detained for
questioning is that still the case
yeah so if anyone was was detained it's
more than likely witness
type information that i'm uh currently
so
uh obviously any businesses we'd want to
have them immediately
to be able to talk to them but that that
that's the best i can give you right now
and then the officer who was shot was he
the one who returned fire do you know
that yeah
that that detail we can't go into at
this point
sir you were chief of this police
department for many years and you know
the community well
what's it like to be back here like this
happening in this community
you know it's it's a sad day you know
it's unfortunate as
as chief mentioned you know these are
the days you don't ever want to get this
phone call
right and uh obviously because of my
connection uh
it was important for me to be here i you
know i i was
close by thank goodness um in in the uh
in the region and so
um you know i i wanted to come by and
make sure
a couple things right is uh to let folks
know that that our investigators are on
it
uh we will conduct our investigation
thoroughly we'll we'll gather all the
facts and we'll present those facts as
we do in
any uh incident that we're called to
handle
um and then you know and it's it's to
you know visit this community that i
love you know i've spent a lot of time
here in this community and so
um you know it's uh it's a sad day for
knoxville and uh
and it's tough for austin east you know
we've spent a lot of time when i was
here
i spent a lot of time working at austin
east and uh you know
had i've got some great memories of of
interactions with the students there and
the staff there and so um it's a it's
it's difficult
right and so uh you know my prayer is
that the community will
will come together you know don't let
this be divisive
uh come together let's continue to work
i know this week was
identified as you know youth violence
interruption week or something of that
nature and
uh and so you know this is a tough way
to start a week that you're
focusing on trying to keep people safe
right
uh i know there was a great event this
weekend you know
uh by the change center and uh you know
and there was people having fun and
relaxing and enjoying each other's
uh company and so you know we need more
of that less of this
is what that that's my gut tells me that
to to share
you know and more than anything just uh
just what a sad day
uh you know for the family that lost
their loved one and uh for the families
of the the the officers that had had to
get engaged in this
did officers have bodyboard cameras and
if so were they on
you would i i believe there is body one
camera footage as i understand chief
could you speak really quickly to the
response we saw from
even all kinds of agencies and officers
what's it like
when that call goes out on the radio
so yes i've heard from many different
agencies all
you know offering their prayers and
their support um and it's
that is a great feeling um it's a great
feeling that you know
when we call for and ask for tbi's help
and they
they come um it's it's a great feeling
to know that
the director roush has come personally
um
you know we've served many years
together and it means a lot to me
personally
when officers were first called i mean
there were just so many
squad cars there so many police officers
there from the sheriff's office from kpd
i mean it sounds like almost every
officer in the city responded
why well we have a student
you know a school incident it's our
worst it's our
our worst fear is an active shooter in a
school
um those are our kids most of us are
parents those of us who aren't
you know we all have a soft spot in our
hearts for kids
we don't want anything to ever happen at
a school that's
that's that's the worst thing that we
we see happening and then to hear
involved also
you then initially we locked down the
school we wanted to make sure that we
had
the people involved under control
you